Hey hello everybody thank you very much
for coming to this talk finally
javascript is easy if you look very
carefully the title is maybe slightly
different to what you thought
there are quotation marks around the
title okay our quotation marks around
the title this is what we all say in the
JavaScript ecosystem when a new
framework or a new library is released
and we start playing with it and we have
our first hello world scenario running
we say yes we have it at last
that is what this talk is about so here
is the abstract what you went for
JavaScript can it be used reliably in
business applications in large business
applications in enterprise settings
that's the that's the context and we're
going to look a little bit at what
different enterprises are doing larger
organizations including some very
unexpected organizations and what
they're doing with JavaScript and we see
some of their websites and pages and so
on and in particular we're going to take
a look at one of these which is a
solution by Oracle free open source
these are all free and open source
solutions that I want to focus on in
particular on the front end and these
are the key takeaways so we're going to
take a look at the whole JavaScript
landscape the whole ecosystem as it is
what enterprises are doing in that
context how they are solving real
problems angular everyone knows about
I'm going to look at some alternatives
and you're going to look at in in a
little bit of detail at one particular
implementation and a bit more so my name
is herion I used to work in Sun
Microsystems a lot on the Java side of
things and I've been involved in Oracle
since the takeover of Sun by Oracle and
I've been increasingly focused on
JavaScript I'm a very I'm a very
skeptical JavaScript user I'm not an
enthusiastic JavaScript user let's say I
think like many people coming from a
from a Java background I'm sure many
people here as well but we need to do
something with JavaScript clearly there
is an incredible amount of
innovation taking place there and that I
want to talk about a little bit as well
actually I don't only come from the from
the Java ecosystem but specifically from
the Java swing Equus
ecosystem and I still think Java swing
is a really wonderful technology and
it's still widely used you just you just
don't have people working in air traffic
control systems and Mission Control NASA
applications and military operations
tweeting about all the things that
they're doing normally so it's it's
there it's used in various specialized
scenarios very specialized scientific
applications still and I've always been
very fascinated by that particular
domain that that enterprise scientific
enterprise domain and I'll still end and
I can see that there is a place coming
in that can of space for for JavaScript
as well in enterprise settings in
different settings to these but but
definitely in an enterprise context I've
also been involved a long time with a
little project called NetBeans I used to
work in Sun in Prague in the Czech
Republic where NetBeans was created and
you may or may not know but at the
moment we're in a Mileva process of
moving NetBeans to Apache so NetBeans is
going to be an Apache project like maven
or groovy or whatever so patching
NetBeans and Oracle remains heavily
involved you can see here a long list of
modules of NetBeans that are already in
Apache you know at the end you'll see
how to set everything up you do a git
clone you run ant and you have NetBeans
9 and with Java 9 features we're also in
the process of moving over the Java EE
tooling and the Java Script tuning and
all the different features of NetBeans
into Apache and you're gonna see
actually also who the contributors are
and what is really nice very quickly
after we started this process of moving
to Apache we discovered that many people
are involved that we never knew existed
so completely new people that have been
using NetBeans for years but have not
been able to contribute to NetBeans
because it was part of Oracle for
various reasons are much more able much
more enthusiastic about contributing to
something that is part of Apache
and so you can join in and um help and
add your missing features or support for
your particular technologies and so on
to an Apache project the one and only
Apache project that provides a
development environment complete
development environment Java JavaScript
PHP C++ groovy API is for other
languages other technologies
so really the sky's the limit and you
you warmly invited to join and
everything is discussed and decided
together there's no one company that
dominates it's just a lot of individual
people there are no companies and Apache
just individual contributors and so
please feel free to join in but to the
topic this is what business applications
look like a lot nowadays there are
mobile devices that they do business
things very specific business thing so
you can see here for example a a Tesco
application for managing the internal
employees at Tesco you see here a
healthcare related application with
blood work results so you can see a
graph chart type component there you can
see integration with with a map and also
the final screenshot shows you a mobile
app that's being translated in
internationalized in this case into
Russian and actually already just from
these simple screenshots you see a whole
range of typical enterprise-e concerns
for example internationalization for
example being able to render large sets
of data into interesting visualizations
like graphs and charts integration with
maps and these are typical concerns that
you have when you're creating front ends
of of
enterprise applications nowadays when
they're targeted at mobile devices and
even when you're not targeting mobile
devices with your with your front end a
front end nowadays has very specific
requirements as well in the context of
the desktop browser so even if it's just
running on the desktop browser you still
want the application to be far more
appealing and it used to be far more
appealing for more attractive you want
to have all these kinds of graphical
components as
graphs and charts also grids and tables
and these kinds of collection oriented
components to visualize large sets of
data to the user so this already gives
you a bit of a feeling of the kinds of
concerns that one has in the enterprise
and what kinds of solutions we need to
to look for and the context of Oracle
there's there have been all kinds of
technologies for a while
that provide solutions in this space but
these solutions in the context of our
ago have always been very specific and
so if you are not in the ecosystem
you've never heard of these technologies
but outside of our code there's you know
this massive proliferation of frameworks
and libraries
you know this the angular backbone and
ember and you know every week there's a
new JavaScript solution in the same way
is about I don't know seven eight years
ago that was all about then every you
know every month or so there would be a
new Java server framework you know there
was you know you know the struts and the
stripes and and the JSF this and all
this tapestry all this thing right every
few months there was a new one in that
space and this is what is what is
clearly happened in the JavaScript
ecosystem all these new libraries have
come out and you know for example you
know Grudge as a build system and you
spend some time learning grunts and if
you are really happy with your grunt
knowledge and then your colleague says -
yes but everyone's doing gulp nowadays
so then you learn gulp we spend some
sometimes and weeks a month or two doing
in gulp and you're very happy with the
gulp knowledge and it turns our branch
is the new gulp so this is this this
constant churn of technologies it's very
interesting it's very interesting but if
you're in the enterprise context versus
being a hobbyist at home it's it's not
about being interesting it's about being
stable and reliable or being productive
and not having all your libraries
dropping out of out of the sky every
couple of months and disappearing and
not being supported I'm not being
documented and all these things so the
enterprise is is has very different
requirements and one of them is not what
is interesting or what is cool it's what
is stable what is reliable what will
still be there and in some form half a
year three years five years from now
so a lot of organizations in the
enterprise have made some very
interesting developments over the last
few years that are quite surprising it's
one thing that these large organizations
for example Oracle IBM Microsoft and so
on are using javascript especially on
the front especially on the front end
but it's another thing that
organizations like PayPal are doing that
and another example is Walmart you know
that Walmart has an open-source division
did you know that PayPal has an
open-source division so not only are
these typical enterprises that the SA PE
and the Google and Microsoft and so on
doing things in this space but these
other organizations that you wouldn't
really expect are doing are using Java
scripts but going further than that they
are contributing back so in the case of
PayPal
they had this internal stack based on
nodejs so they started with Nijs and
then I used Express on top of that as
you would in most cases with with node
and and then they developed their own
components and I developed this over a
number of years and at some point they
said hey why not why not open sources so
they created this project Kraken jeaious
and they have this nice thing on the top
right paper open source another VP of
PayPal can go to conferences and talk to
developers and say hey look we're doing
all these things cannot work for us
because at the same time what is also
driving this development I think is that
there is a shortage of developers you
know every one of the one of the
consequences of this whole IRT
revolution and and and so on is that
every organization nowadays is an IT
organization now Walmart you wouldn't
maybe think of as an IT organization but
it's also night it's it's awesome IT
organization every conceivable business
is an IT organization which means
there's a massive demand for developers
and all these organizations are
competing for developers I imagine if
you were to I'm going an interview with
Oracle and you know ask Oracle ok so if
I work for you at Oracle what
technologies will ever using Oracle says
to you you will be using ADF apex and
forms
and then you say well in two or three
years I won't be here anymore because
that's like everyone else
so developers want to move on to
something else I want to be able to use
these technologies I want to be able to
use all these JavaScript oriented
open-source technologies because
anything I learn in this organization I
won't be able to continue to be using
somewhere else so this is exactly what's
happening and so I think this is also
what's driving these these developments
so Kraken is this
open source stack from PayPal Walmart
has an open source stack so you can just
go to crack and jazz comm you see that
they've started with node and they're
put on top of that express and in their
own solutions and they have a whole page
very attractive and interesting looking
and then you go to an electrode dot IO
again they started with nodejs
and they use react this is a very
popular combination and react very
popular nodes very popular and this is
how Walmart is doing things now what is
also very appealing about this approach
is that if you create your application
on top of one of these stacks then you
know that PayPal is using that stack too
and that Walmart is using that stack too
and it turns out that there's a similar
situation at the Financial Times that
you know not that there's actually a
Financial Times for developers so they
have our stack as well that you can
build your solutions on top of so rather
than kind of going to Google and
googling for different libraries and
kind of sticking them together and you
know not being sure how they work
together and then googling and finding a
solution for one problem but that means
that that solution applies if you're
using these three libraries but seven
other libraries as well that's when that
solution that you find make sense and
these problems you don't have when you
build your solution on top of one of
these enterprise stacks especially if
there are open source enterprise stacks
so Kraken electrode and financial times
one interesting to look at but there are
so many others but these ones I found
interesting because that's from places
you wouldn't necessarily expect that to
come from now what all of these have in
common is this set
requirements if your enterprise these
are the kinds of things that you
consumed about not what is cool or what
was created yesterday or what my buddy
is raving about but these are the kinds
of things that that are important
stability the most difficult thing to
achieve in the JavaScript ecosystem
which is so innovative which is great
of course innovation is great but where
do you find that balance stability a
proven tool set
responsive design you know that's a
basic requirement you don't want to have
to figure out how to do responsive
design you won't have an out-of-the-box
solution that does responsive design and
build your business logic on top of that
concerns about accessibility and
internationalization are again not
concerns of a hobby project but they
enterprise there are all kinds of
requirements and specifications that
large enterprises need to adhere to and
in that area and you need that to be
solved you don't want have to figure
that out yourself and data
visualizations are graphs charts they
want that to be a coherent solution not
a separate library somewhere but you
wanted to be as standard part of a stack
security big concern how do you solve
this from you know what other problems
their performance and optimization in
that area conformance to standards there
are so many standards out there I'm
finding the right ones and and trying to
follow them etc and a web component
standard the css3 module based standards
and flexbox and so on also you want to
not only focus on code developers with
solutions if you're in the enterprise
you would also like to have maybe some
solutions for business users so some
kind of drag drop clicking things
together for somebody who is not a code
developer but who wants to put a quick
sales presentation together with real
data a quick way to to click an
application together in that context
would be very relevant and finally a
documentation and support to things
which typically you don't have in the
JavaScript ecosystem you have something
kind of thrown together and supports
often very difficult to get as well so
these are typical Enterprise
requirements okay so I've discussed
these other these other contexts I want
to go
it's the specific use case as one
example of this in Oracle so an Oracle
the decision was taken to start off with
these ones so where PayPal took node and
Express and where Walmart took correct
and and node in Oracle the decision is
it's not going to be and it's not going
to be determined by Oracle what the
backend is so the whole back-end is open
typically arrest web sockets but it's
all about the front-end so there is a
solution free open source solution that
is heavily used inside Oracle but it's a
variable for anyone else to use for free
yeah I don't have to ask anybody you can
just use it it's on github
based on these libraries so anyone who's
doing JavaScript and the front-end is
doing jQuery to some extent and then
this jQuery UI as the basis of widgets
and ultimately that would be web
components as a basis not out for data
binding require for modularity neither
of which are very hot new cool solutions
knockout has been there for a while
everyone's heard of it he does front-end
but in the meantime you doing react are
you doing view or you doing something
else but again those aren't newish
solutions especially view view is very
cool but it's kind of new so knockout a
stable reliable it's been there for a
while has a community has documentation
has tutorials has all these different
things so knockout for data binding and
requirejs as the modularity solution and
then cordova as the mechanism to get the
application as an APK or an iOS file or
a Windows Windows file onto mobile
devices of course Apache Cordova means
that you don't get the ultimately
performant application on your phone but
that's not what you need if you're
creating enterprise applications of
course you want the applications to be
performant but you don't necessarily
need that kind of speed and performance
that you get from native development
which next sends for games and so on but
in enterprise this is fine it is it does
its job perfectly well so here is that
architecture so this specific
architecture is how oracle is solving
these problems and internally as as a
solution inside of Oracle and because
within that organization and it's really
an organization consisting of notes for
other organizations it's an enterprise
consisting of other companies really Oh
doing different things and some of them
were doing angular and some of them were
doing Accenture and some were doing X
and someone doing backbone and at some
point a decision was made let's all have
the same architecture so this is a very
common development in large enterprises
after all the experimentation
after all the playing around with
different solutions you need to as an
organization decide ok these are the
choices we're going to make and
importantly I think the most important
choice in that context is to think about
the architecture because things are
going to change that's that's the only
sure thing in the JavaScript ecosystem
six months from now there will be three
new libraries that would change the
world and two years later though we five
other things you know so you need to
have an architecture that is adaptable
that is probably the most important
message to take away from this if you're
in the enterprise and you exploring
JavaScript especially on the front end
and you see all these libraries and
frameworks and whatever out there the
most important thing to think about is
to think about the architecture and
about separation of concerns and about
what happens if this layer changes if
there's a revolutionary new solution on
this layer what are we the consequences
of that can I swap out what I have and
put in this this new solution but that
isn't there yet but that will inevitably
come so here the architecture decided is
for the for the data binding layer in
this model view viewmodel
architecture and the data binding layer
on the view model is knocked out the
model could be jQuery and but there's
also built in a backbone based solution
so if you're familiar with backbone
collections and backbone models so
backbone model backbone collection that
syntax is built into this as well so
there's a backbone syntax or a jQuery
on the level of connecting to the to the
server which can be anything typically
you would have rest a WebSocket knockout
for data binding which you could take
out optionally but that's the that's a
default data binding layer and then the
highest layer has has a range of
components which you can include into
the application and there's a routing
mechanism and then this requires is for
modularity the final slide before I do
some demos these are the key ideas and I
think the most important concepts to
think about when you're coming up with a
solution for your own organization the
most important point adaptability to
change and to come up with a browser
focus solution so really a front end
solution back and rest WebSockets
typical modern back end data providers
macro services etc modern so css3 html5
JavaScript and gets you onto a mobile
device easily via Cordova and JavaScript
open source Enterprise ready such
solutions for internationalization
solutions for accessibility solutions
for visualizing large data sets
solutions for architecture for
templating for modularity these are
concerns that you need to consider and
also a very important point here a
toolkit not framework so here narrowly
I'm talking now about the specific
solution here which is called Oracle jet
where the tea so it stands for
javascript extension toolkit the T
stands for toolkit it's not Oracle Jeff
it's Oracle jet framework I think it's a
problem and I think people using angular
may have experienced this when you move
from angular 1 to angular 2 or you know
those kinds of changes does basically
means rewriting everything because the
the framework approach implies but it's
more or less a closed ecosystem it
provides everything maybe you don't need
everything but here is everything you
build your application on top and then
when there's a big release change you
need to rewrite all kinds of things and
move it to the next release and
essentially rewrite the application that
a consequence of a framework approach
and it's part of this always ongoing
discussion about framework versus
library do you choose a framework that
provides everything or do you come up
with a set of libraries that provides
everything you need and you couple those
libraries together and both have
advantages and disadvantages I would say
in the context of the JavaScript
ecosystem because you want to be
adaptable you need to have something and
it's modular and that it's flexible and
this is the key motivator beneath this
particular solution so to get started
with this it's quite easy you install
via NPM a small command-line interface
which I have done so I'm gonna go to my
very nicely organized desktop which was
a complete mess ten minutes ago but I
cleaned everything up so it looks really
clean and so here I am on my command
line in another terminal window here we
go terminal so I want to CD into my
desktop and you can see is a folder
there called aura dev and Here I am
artists okay so now I want to say a jet
create and what shall we courage
logistics analysis sis and we specify a
template number of different templates
provide an outline press ENTER and then
and the process begins so this is tool
you can see the utility code oujet and
initially what the solution was is you
had to use NPM you have to use yeoman
and it turned out that many people
didn't know about NPM doesn't know about
yeoman so that to learn NPM and yawen
and so in the latest release a decision
was made let's not use NPM and yeoman we
were hided underneath this command-line
interface so you installed the
command-line interface and you have
under the hood in TM in yeoman okay so
we got into that
folder so what do we have logistics
analysis I'm in here
I say jet serve and application starts
up in the browser here it is so within
two minutes what I have is an
application that is responsive so take a
look what it looks like when I make it
smaller you can see it I have this very
typical menu bar like you would expect
on the left-hand side with a hamburger
icon on mobile devices and now I have a
standard menu bar so out-of-the-box
responsive application with different
tabs along the top some basic content so
now I'm going to open it and this is
where NetBeans comes in but you can use
any editor you that you like when you
use Java scripts but a nice feature in
this context about NetBeans is that
because there is a package.json file in
that folder
NetBeans knows this is a project so it
means parses the package.json file and
we get the application so now the first
thing to notice if you can see on the
top left there is this this structure so
you can see here we have a view models
folder and we have a views folder now
this is here a convention of the
configuration all applications that make
use of this architecture on top of
Oracle's javascript extension toolkit
have the same architecture very
convenient when somebody in Oracle moves
for one organization to another
organization this have to spend no time
understanding the architecture because
there's a common architecture you can
override this however you like and so on
but this is the basic architecture so
here you can see there's a views folder
with HTML files and a view mods models
folder with Java Script files you look
in the browser you can see we have these
four tabs dashboard incidents customers
about and I'm looking here and I have
dashboard
incidents customer is about so here is
the dashboard HTML so pure HTML file and
hand it off to my web designer that can
do pure HTML there and here is my Java
Script which is a defined block from
requirejs so this is a requirejs module
okay so here's all my business logic in
here and and the other one and in the
other one in the HTML file is where I
put my my view so now look in the
browser it says your dashboard content
area I can see your dashboard content
area so I'm going to say hello
Momo that there save it look in the
browser and now I can see how my mom oh
why because the command line interface
keeps track of my project and whenever I
make a change and I save it
the that command line interface reloads
that file into the browser okay so now I
have this content within you know two
minutes everything set up so now I'm
going to go and add some components so
here's the component library all kinds
of components so if you're using a d3 or
all kinds of other component libraries
look at this one free open source it's
on github let's take for example diagram
or it's like a chart here here are the
charts one of them is a bar chart so
here we can see in the browser see a
chart and we see buttons along the
bottom so I think I can change the view
here but I think about I don't want this
in my application so I can tweak it live
in the browser so here is a an element
called edge a toolbar on the right there
so now I said delete and I say apply and
now the toolbar is gone so I can tweak
what I see so this is a recipe for that
component okay so now I'm happy I like
how this looks I copy this and I paste
it right there
okay that's gonna format things a little
bit and set things up okay so here we
are so here you can see a chart so
here's a custom element it's a bar chart
type bar and so it could be line could
be pie could be whatever as you will see
and there is JavaScript so you can see
here that there are keys and values so
orientation orientation value stacks
like value these square braces mean
one-way data-binding
so this is this is a read-only
connection if you use curly braces as we
were in a moment you see that that is
for two-way data-binding
readwrite property so I'll copy these
properties and I paste them into my
JavaScript so it's JavaScript side so
everything's nicely organized here as
you can see here the properties and here
I could use jQuery to get the real data
I would make my connection from here to
my back-end service to get my data but
right now it's hard-coded final step
we're going to include you have to load
the components that we're using so these
are like this is like an import
statement in Java using a define block
from require so we have to import the AJ
chart because we're using that we have
this we have that copied everything make
no changes and they will see our chart
we're in a slow chart so you can see
that if you go back here now I'm going
to change this bar to PI for example
save this look back here now I have a
pie chart now wouldn't it be nice if we
had a drop-down list here so that the
user can select bar or or pie so there's
an another component which is a
drop-down list so again here's a recipe
but we don't want to have these browsers
in the drop-down list we want to have
bar and pie so I'm going to go in here
and I'm just going to update this
directly in the browser bar and the bar
in there so this is bar chart and here
is a pie chart here is pie so I remove
these ones
then I click apply' bar in PI and we can
see bar and we can see PI so as I change
you can see that this is updated so this
is working as I would want so now I copy
this copy that go in here so I just
place it in here and paste for a message
okay so I add here my little combo combo
box slow drop down and also notices at
the combo box I can type directly into
it you see that in a minute and because
you have your support for filtering you
can see here as I type
so filtering built into that into that
drop-down so here is the here's the HTML
so I go in here
and now here there is you can see a
reference to a value named Val okay so I
go into the JavaScript here is my value
name Val copy that go back in here and I
paste it into the JavaScript here we go
and so here it is so we'll make our
initial one you set it to PI here's K
our observable so this is knockout not
how to do the getter and setter and and
property change listening and everything
for us that's why we're using knockout
here to keep track of that value and
inform any place where it's being
referenced now back in here and you can
see that there is AZ value that set you
there with curly braces so that enables
this means to lay data binding go back
into the browser
which I can look here and we haven't
loaded our component yet so we go back
in here and we copy that component and
we paste it reference to that component
that we are now using there it is it'll
go back and we see in the browser that
that the list is there but it doesn't
work yet we have this we have this combo
box it doesn't work why because looking
in the HTML this is hard-coded the type
is set to PI but it should be set
instead to Val
and so I changed this put it in there
Ravel now we go in here and you can see
that it's automatically updated so this
is how it basically works you setup your
application with the command-line
interface very easily very quickly you
have a cookbook full of different
components that you can copy and paste
directly tweak in the browser and then
run run and and use it from there
speaking of those enterprise features
and you can see I have an English text
and I've here an English calendar
component a date and time picker when I
switch to French now you can see I have
a French date and time picker now I have
a check date and time picker so these
this is one of the components from
oracle chat compared library but all the
labels have been translated
automatically for you so there's a lots
of bundle files included for all the
labels and if you switch the Arabic you
don't only get an Arabic calendar but
you also get right-to-left support so
you can see here when I switch to Arabic
this is two lines of JavaScript and now
we have a Java Script an Arabic calendar
and we have right-to-left support which
is very easy to do a typical requirement
for larger applications and a final
small demo about web components so this
is what everyone is interested in and at
the moment and so you can see that I
have this little widget here that I it's
pretty interesting too took a bit of
work to create this so I'm showing us to
my colleague and my colleague says hey
it wouldn't be nice if you could somehow
extract that widget out of your
application and share it with me or you
can because this is based on the web
component standard and you can see that
we are in the library page here in the
library module I go to the library
module and then you can see that there
is here library library j/s so here is
the data so here is hard-coded the the
two names that are here and here is the
library HTML file and here you can see a
custom element so first of all you can
see here for each so this is how an
account does for each loops and but you
can also see there a custom element
called demo
obviously this is not a an HTML element
that is part of the specification this
is something that I created and I
created that and I loaded it into the
module by means of this reference here
so there's a reference to jet composites
slash demo card slash loader let's take
a look here so here it is
jet composites slash demo card slash
loader here is a definition of demo card
this because of this line here I am able
to say here demo card and this loaded is
file defines the JavaScript files and
HTML files that constitutes that widget
and our found in the same folder most
importantly of all so in one folder I
have the definition of this widget which
means I can zip up that folder and send
that zip file to my colleague they can
unzip it into their application and load
it into their module and then use it so
this makes possible the concept of a
marketplace where not only are a good
jet components might be shared but also
angular components or react components
of view components so long as all of
these different libraries and frameworks
adhere to the web components standard
one could imagine a generic catalog or
marketplace of some kind for components
that can be interchanged across
different technologies and the next step
is take a look at this this is a memory
game and you can see it's a memory game
you can see I'm not very good at it
though but the point is that this game
is one widget so it's a which is called
game and each of the cards within it
this is also widget so there's a card
that's a widget and there's the game
that's a widget so you can correct
hierarchical structures and this is
within Oracle definitely the way that
more and more applications are going to
be written because there are so many
different applications inside Oracle
what is going to happen is that one
organization will write a task list
component and another one who writes a
calendar component and those different
organizations will share those common
components with each other
so actually via JavaScript we act
getting to a place where we were able to
do real component based development
create a component once using using
javascript in the architecture and the
philosophy that Jetts provides and then
share it with everyone else
and make those those generic components
available so that is the basic story
this is how Oracle is solving this
particular set of problems and you're
very welcome to use this solution in the
same way as you can use Kraken or you
can use an electrode and so on there's a
learned page where you will see
tutorials is a MOOC you can follow a
free tech three weeks you learn
everything in that time there's a
success stories page where if your
organization uses this as you can see
more and more organizations are making
use of this set of solutions and we will
happily promote that you know your work
that's done and the organization as a
whole there's a support page where you
see there's a forum where you can ask
questions there's an F acute as a blog
there's a developer guide so in addition
to that cookbook there's a guide with
chapters on topics like how do you
design responsive applications you know
the question a question worth asking and
investigating how do you do single page
application and design so these kinds of
questions are answered and within this
within these documents as well so in in
the context of Oracle what we are what
you are doing is we are very carefully
embracing this JavaScript ecosystem and
the most important step that we have
taken is to think about the architecture
and about the modularity of that
architecture so if you look in the in
the organization of that logistics
analysis application for example take a
look in the web folder and you can see
the libraries that are in here
libraries are there's nothing strange in
here this jQuery which anyone that does
Java Script uses there's no cards for
data binding this AJ so these are the
Oracle Jet's components
there's require for modularity this
polyfills in there there's hammer for
touch of mobile devices and if you want
to change anything if you want to add
new new new libraries or new components
there's the required
configuration file I mean this is simply
a collection of require plus knockout
plus plus jQuery and so on so there's
the configuration file that require
provides where you can register new
libraries of your choice or you can
remove libraries from here the ones that
you don't need so it's really flexible
and aimed at embracing change which i
think is the is the key message that i
want to leave you with if you are in an
enterprise settings if you're in
healthcare or in finance or in logistics
and these kinds of these kinds of
contexts and you're looking at
JavaScript as a front-end solution and
you're worried about this this constant
innovation in this ecosystem now first
of all you're right to be worried about
it and and then the next thing is to is
to recognize that the most important
thing in response to that is to think
about the architecture of your solution
and not to get locked in to a framework
not to get locked in to one particular
company but to focus on being as
flexible as possible while at the same
time being able to benefit from what
organizations like PayPal and you know
Walmart and Oracle and IBM and etc are
doing and trying to find a careful
balance between that but I think the
fact that not only are these large
enterprises using javascript but they're
contributing javascript toolkits and
frameworks back to the community it's
really a sign that the enterprise has
embraced javascript as a solution and
are just trying to figure out how to
solve these problems of innovation but
javascript is here in the front change
and not just in Hubli projects and not
just in small startups or whatever but
in large enterprise systems with all the
consequences of that but everyone is
trying to figure out the best way
forward and that's the key message I
want to leave you with to think about
these different approaches but to more
or less accept that in in these kinds of
especially customer facing type
front-ends javascript is really is
really here to stay
thank you very much
[Applause]